we're hanging here with the awesome lily
thing
who i just so deeply respect and admire
and then i discovered we share a passion
wins twinsies um
your kitchen looks real bougie i'm real
jealous and i'm so excited
yeah it's totally bougie you're so right
because i was like
i need people to get out of their houses
and into a nice destination
but the fact that you chose to go back
into a house
is just so smart and i love that we're
both
trying to figure this out to be true to
ourselves
and yet entertain people and build a
community
i really do feel a lot of symmetry with
you lily
i couldn't agree more i couldn't agree
more and the fact that we're about to
make some cheesy mac and cheese
and then we have the glue that truly
binds
um okay i know you have a mac and cheese
cabinet
which is i mean i knew that i
felt a connection to you but i had
here's the thing are we doing original
craft dinner mac and cheese are we doing
like one of the
other ones are we doing like a creamy
are we doing an extra cheesy what are we
doing here
i'll demonstrate because i have a real
passion for the deluxe
but what i make for my daughters and
what i've also
grown up on and i'm very passionate
about is the powder so
you say you have the perfect mac and
cheese recipe
and can you take me through it because
this is
an art a hundred percent this should be
on my resume
so the pot has the pasta in it correct
is it is it strained it is straight
amazing okay what people don't
understand is you need to leave the
stove on
a low temperature throughout this
process so
the first thing i would do is i would
actually put butter how much
don't be shy okay we're not making salad
here i would say like you know whatever
makes you happy
i'm gonna get you know what i'm very
impressed with that amount that is
probably double what i would put but i'm
not mad
really like a good like three
tablespoons like it's like
half a stick you know because again lily
this isn't salad of course if you're
gonna go lean all the way in 100 this is
not the time to be
dainty absolutely no we're making
deluxe here we're splurging okay while
this is melting i actually put
the powder in so the powder and the
butter can kind of be together and then
i put a little bit of milk as well yeah
there you go
so when we do the milk this is where you
have to go little by little you don't
want to dump the whole thing in
you incorporate a little bit of milk
just to splash
and then you start you start mixing to
see where you're at
that boom i would stop right there
exactly um
now fun fact kraft macaroni and cheese
um one of its best-selling uh
like collabs was the spongebob
shaped pasta i did not
know that jude did you know that for
this valentine's day i heard a rumor
about
they're releasing a special pink mac and
cheese that tastes like
candy i thought it was just like red
pasta with the same sauce which i
thought was really neat i didn't know it
was sweet
but maybe lily we could try it and let
each other know what we think
i'm down your consistency looks real
good real good is the butter all melted
the butter is almost all melted wait i
hear you have some
um can i try it for sure i hear you have
some cheesy jokes
oh okay i'll give you one uh did you
hear
this is actually a real one did you hear
about the near my house there was a
cheese factory that exploded
no yeah there was debris everywhere
i don't know why but i got way too
cerebral with that joke
i was like garbage what does garbage
have to do with it
how's the mac and cheese oh
i'm so jealous it's just
it's perfect it's perfect the way it is
i feel very strongly about this you know
what else is perfect the way it is
no oh no you don't you
that you're eating mac and cheese i'm
living vicariously through you and i i
know it's making you so happy so it's
making me happy
well let's try the valentine's day at
one and see what we think
and then let's be sisters on the
airwaves you know
sure trying to put ourselves
optimism um be a part of what really
it is i love that we don't just show up
and say our lines like
these shows for better or worse are a
huge part of
us and from your life and
you know i i really appreciate you
being willing also to share yourself
and being a creative force you know
having
um an idea and and seeing it through
and showing up at the table not
empty-handed that's what you do and i
really love it
and um be sure to check out um a little
late with lily singh weeknights
on nbc of course